So let's take a look at the structure of
paradise as it's presented in the in
genesis.
So the first aspect of the initial
paradisical state is unself
consciousness.
Now,
if you look at factor at an analytic
studies of human personality,
you note that self consciousness,
although it is arguably our greatest
gift,
also loads almost entirely on the factor
that defines negative effect.
And you might also notice that when you
say I became self conscious,
you generally put a negative cast on
that in that I was talking before a
group of people and suddenly I was
seized by self consciousness.
And as a consequence of that,
I was flooded by negative emotion and
was fundamentally a mobilized.
So it's a very paradoxical,
a very paradoxical state of being that
our highest a gift say,
and the only one that clearly
distinguishes us from animals is also
that which when manifested,
makes us almost unbearably anxious.
The initial paradise state when Adam and
eve first walk in the garden of Eden is
characterized by an animal like unself
consciousness,
Adam and eve,
whatever they are,
are not clearly segregated from the rest
of the world.
They have no idea,
for example,
of their own nakedness,
and if you think about what nakedness
means,
you immediately understand that that's
also a very profound dramatic
representation,
you know,
with children that are around the age of
three or four.
Many of them,
regardless of their motive upbringing,
start to become very concerned about
privacy,
say with regards to bodily functions and
also very concerned about ever showing
themselves without clothing and it's
perfectly reasonable to presume that
that's a consequence of their emergent
self consciousness and event that takes
place somewhere between the ages of two
and five and that's a defining moment,
right?
That makes them segregated,
will say from their mother.
And so you also have images of paradise
that float through Western history that
are characterized by the image of the
unconscious union between the mother and
child.
Right,
which is a which has an images stick
representation that eradicates the
tension of self consciousness both for
the mother and for the child.
So the notion that the child is living
in a paradise will condition that
somehow lost as he or she approaches
adulthood gives another sort of symbolic
layer.
The notion of the pre self conscious
paradise,
it's also a place where order in chaos
are imperfect balance and you know that
because what paradise means is para
around days a,
a wall while Eden means delight or a
place of delight.
Paradise Paradise is a walled garden,
a wild place of delight and a garden is
precisely that place where the forces of
nature or chaos and the forces of
culture are held in perfect balance,
right?
That's what a garden is,
its nature given form by culture and
it's a place that's architecturally
pleasant,
a place where the intervention of human
activity has produced a kind of
stability that transcends that of nature
because it's a cultural construct,
but also that transcends that of culture
because all of the plants and the other
growing things that constitute a garden
are somehow transcendent even though
they're under the cultivating hand of
culture and the individual.
If you look at the manner in which the
fall story is represented,
you all can also see that the place of
previous stability can be regarded as a
kind of paradise.
So if you remember the story of Moses
leading his people through the desert,
it's clearly the case that when the
Israelites were in the desert,
even though they got away from the
tyranny,
it was easy to look back and say,
well,
you know,
tough as it was,
the place that we were before.
It was much better than the place we are
now.
So it's perfectly reasonable and
expectable for people who are caught in
a crisis to look back to the time prior
to the dawn of that crisis with longing,
even if the crisis that they're
presently experiencing is a necessary
precondition for further development of
personality.
So the story that's laid out in genesis
has has its structure.
Something like this,
before we became self conscious,
the world was perfect as a consequence
of the rise of self consciousness.
We were thrown out of the Garden of Eden
out of Paradise and destined to live the
profane existence that characterizes our
president mode of being where we're
subject to knowledge of mortality and
the possibility of illness and
alienation from God.
And wouldn't it be ever so great if we
could only return to that condition of
unsolved consciousness and make all our
problems go away and you see this kind
of pathological paradisical reminiscence
manifesting itself in the most banal
forms of conservatism,
which are always projecting the ideal,
the ideal past somewhere back into the
unattainable reaches of time and also in
those situations that obtained
psychologically when people are
absolutely possessed by depression and
anxiety and wish for their consciousness
to come to an end,
if not metaphorically so they desire to
sleep.
Then actually so that suicide is viewed
as a kind of unconsciousness who's
paradisical nature.
The absence of all opposition is viewed
as clearly preferable to the
difficulties of actually maintaining.
Being
Julianna says,
the idea of paradise once and then
paradise lost is not something unique to
western or a great eastern societies.
It's a widespread motif just as wide as
this as the flood motif.
Regardless of where you go in the world,
you find this notion when heaven had
been abruptly separated from the earth,
that is when it had become remote.
As in our days when the tree or vine
connecting Earth to heaven had been cut
or the mountain which used to touch the
sky had been flattened out,
then the paradisical stage was over and
man entered into his present fallen
condition.
In fact,
all myths of Paradise show us primordial
man enjoying a beatitude,
spontaneity and freedom,
which he has unfortunately lost in
consequence of the fall that is of what
followed upon the mythical event that
caused the rupture between heaven and
earth.
As I said,
Eden is delight,
a place of delight by terminological
definition.
Whereas paradise is a walled garden.
I want to show you what knowing that
does for analysis of the relationship
between eastern and Western thought.
So let me tell you quickly the story of
the Buddha and I'm going to represent it
fundamentally like this.
Buddhist starts his life in what's
essentially a walled garden by all,
by all reasonable comparative analysis
and as a consequence of his emergent
self consciousness.
The unselfconscious childlike perfection
of that early state is permanently
disrupted.
So you have a situation where the
greatest redemption story of the east
follows precisely the same grammatical
track as the greatest creation story of
the West.
So this is the story.
Buddhas farther is visited by an angel
who tells him that his son is going to
grow up to be the greatest temporal
profane ruler the world has ever seen,
or a great spiritual leader and his
father.
Being a pragmatic and conservative man
decides that there's no possible way.
I'm going to allow my son to take the
ambivalent road of spiritual
enlightenment.
I'm going to allow him to fall
completely in love with the world so
that he will remain attached to his
domain.
So prior to Buddha's birth,
his father constructs a great city with
walls around it.
And inside that city he removes all
signs of pain,
frustration,
and disappointment.
Any sign of ugliness,
theat and the only people that are
allowed to exist within the city are
those who are in perfect mental and
physical health who are paragons of
beauty and virtue.
And the idea that lurks behind that
archetypal story is that when a father
has a child,
the his moral obligation is to shield
the developing consciousness of that
child from contact with any of the
horrors of life that could provide the
child with an experienced too traumatic
for that developing consciousness to
apprehend so because it's an archetypal
story that relates to the development of
all people,
not just the redemptive savior,
and that's the motif that the Buddhist
story initially follows at good father
makes his child fall in love with life
by enticing that child into a direct
relationship with all that life has to
offer.
So Buddha grows up within this walled
garden,
this unselfconscious paradise,
but precisely because he's been shielded
to this degree and allowed to mature.
His consciousness continues to expand,
and the world outside the boundaries
that his parents have established for
him starts to attract his attention.
Now we know already that the forbidden
fruit,
right?
The layer of what's outside the walls is
something that human beings just can't
keep their mangy little paws off.
Right?
We are absolutely uncontrollably curious
and the best way to make sure that we
investigate something is to lay down a
structure that says whatever you do
under whatever circumstances,
never look there,
right,
and then the automatic systems that
underlie our orienting and that motivate
our seeking experience are constantly
pulling our attention precisely to that
forbidden spot,
compelling us to investigate exactly
that which has been forbidden.
So because Buddha is a consciousness
developing in a healthy manner,
he immediately becomes curious about
what lies beyond the the limits that
have been established with him and he
makes a decision to go outside of
Paradise.
Right?
Which seems a particularly ridiculous
thing to do given that in principle he
has everything you could possibly want
inside the walls,
but then again we have the troublesome
notion of the original sin of Adam,
right?
Which is if any of you are offered a
forbidden fruit,
again,
under circumstances mythologically
equivalent to those that are obtained in
the beginning,
you'd immediately reach your hand out
and take it.
Because what we haven't got for human
beings is always far more compelling
than what we have got.
So Buddha goes outside the walls,
but his father,
who's a good father,
although somewhat conservative,
decides he's going to rig the game a
little bit so it gets rid of everybody
that's diseased or unhappy or
uncomfortable or ugly or old or anything
that could possibly disturb the Buddha,
any lines,
the streets with flower waving women and
puts pedals on the road and sends his
son out in a gilded chariot.
But the gods who were lurking around
right,
the troublemaking gods who represent
chaos and disorder in the unknown decide
to stand in front of Buddha.
A sick man who hobbles unsteadily
interview.
And Buddha asks his his retainer
precisely what this phenomena represent
sand.
His retainer says,
well,
you know,
human beings like you,
sincere human are subject to the
deterioration of these physical powers
in an arbitrary way.
And this man is one person who's been so
affected and so buddha is completely
disenchanted by his exploratory move out
into the terrible unknown and runs back
into the castle walls and shuts the door
and is perfectly happy to think of
nothing for months.
But then as his anxiety habituates and
his curiosity grows,
he can't stand the notion of never going
outside the walls again and outside.
He goes again and this time where after
his father prepares the route ever so
carefully,
the godsend insight and old man who
hobbles interview and mood,
it looks at him in shock and horror and
says to his retainer,
just precisely what's going on here.
And His retainer says,
well,
that's an old man and everybody gets all
and you're going to get old too.
And that's the way of all humanity.
And that's the point at which voted.
Self consciousness expands not to only
include the possibility of degeneration,
but to include the temporal horizon.
That's characteristic of life.
And he finds that so terribly shocking
that he runs back into the castle and
shuts the walls down and plays with his
friends for another six months or maybe
a year till his anxiety.
Finally habituates.
And he goes out one final time.
And this time the godsend.
A funeral parade for him and he sees his
first dad body.
And this is such a terrible shock to him
that he can't even go back to the
castle.
So his father prepares for him a great
party in the woods near the castle full
of nude dancing women who are perfectly
willing to flaunt themselves and to
offer themselves to him.
But Buddha is so absolutely a
catastrophic,
really shocked by this notion of
emergent death,
that he can't take any pleasure
whatsoever and what's being offered to
him,
and he leaves the kingdom once and for
all.
And you think,
well,
that's exactly what happens to you when
you grow up.
Right?
If you're reasonably well socialized and
properly looked after,
then your curiosity gets the better of
you and you keep going out into the
world until what year parents have
established for you is no longer
sufficient for you.
And as a consequence of that movement
out into the world,
you find out all sorts of things
characteristic of your own life that not
only your parents can't precisely
explain to you,
but even the broader formal structures
of your culture have a very difficult
time handling.
And when you finally do encounter such
realities and allow their effect on you
to fully manifest itself all,
then you're finally independent and you
no longer can return home,
but from that point forward,
you are also burdened as Adam is
burdened when he loses his Paradise Hill
unselfconscious snus with the full
revelation of what it means to be
limited and alive.
So what happens to Buddha as a
consequence of this revelation,
he becomes an apprentice and the
chronicles of the Buddhist adventure are
careful to say that he becomes the
world's most proficient practitioner of
Samka,
which was a philosophical precursor to
yoga and then to yoga so he masters all
the positions and the assanas until he's
disciplined physically to an almost
unlimited degree.
And then he decides that he'll adopt a
stance of world renunciation,
which is also something he's a
remarkably good at.
And he starved himself until the chronic
lewis say he resembles nothing so much
as a pile of dust and then having
exhausted all the disciplinary
structures that his sophisticated
culture has to offer him,
but still not precisely finding the
answer that he's looking for.
He retreats into the forest place of the
unknown and sits himself at the base of
a tree underneath the tree.
He's visited by visions and temptations.
The first division is in essentially
erotic one life itself,
camps him back out of his self conscious
state into the domain of pure physical
pleasure,
a perfectly reasonable temptation,
right,
and one that is powerful enough so that
Hindu philosophers say,
b,
as their churches and cathedrals are
covered with erotic drawings.
If you can't get past the erotic
drawings into the church,
that's the domain that you should still
inhabit,
right in the dawning phases of life at
least till middle age.
That's the appropriate motive being to
be enticed and seduced by the physical
pleasures that life has to offer,
but in the final analysis,
those are not sufficient to solve the
problem of emergent self consciousness
and so the angel of death visits him and
offered him the opportunity to exist
permanently in a state of Nirvana.
A very,
very interesting twist on this story
because you have to wonder,
given the association,
say between suicidality and the notion
of paradise that exists underneath that.
If what Buddha isn't being offered by
the angel of death is in fact death and
this sensation of all the problems of
being regardless,
he rejects that attains enlightenment
briefly and then decides to return to
the world to share what he's discovered
with all of suffering humanity.
The idea being that the Buddha who is
the awakened or enlightened one is
capable of attaining a transcendent
state,
but also knows fully that because human
beings have a shared social aspect,
it is not possible for any one person to
attain redemption until all people
attain redemption.
The reason being that it's very
difficult to be transcendent and
enlightened when you see someone who's
sick lying in a ditch,
so then we shift from that back to
genesis and the attempted fall of man
and read the third chapter,
and they were both naked,
the man and his wife and were not
ashamed.
Well,
what does that mean?
Freud pointed out one of human beings,
most common nightmares is to be stripped
of clothing in front of a crowd.
Now,
why would that be precisely?
Well,
your naked self is the most vulnerable
aspect of you,
right?
Were all closed and for good reason,
partly that's protection from the
terrible natural world,
right,
but it also offers this the possibility
of placing a barrier between ourselves,
our vulnerable cells,
and the searching and critical gaze of
the community,
right?
Because not only are we vulnerable to
the rigors of nature were also
vulnerable to the depredations and
criticisms of society and the notion
that a man and a woman could exist naked
and not know.
It is a clear,
is a clear of finger pointing in the
direction of a story that says these
people were not conscious or if
conscious they certainly were not self
conscious and what's how does the story
develop?
The serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the Lord God
had made and he said unto the woman,
Yea Hath God said you shall not eat of
every tree of the garden.
And the woman said unto the serpent,
well,
we meet of the fruit of the trees,
of the garden,
but of the fruit of the tree which is in
the center of the garden.
God Hath said,
you should not eat of it,
neither shall you touch it,
lest you die,
and the serpent said to the woman,
you won't die,
for God knows that in the day you eat
thereof.
Then your eyes shall be opened,
right?
A clear pointing to the notion of an
awakening and an illumination,
and you should be like gods,
knowing good and evil,
right?
Which attributes to humanity a dawning
sense of morality,
explicit morality of faculty for
comprehension that we do not share with
any other animal,
and when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food and that it was pleasant
to the eyes and a tree to be desired to
make one wise,
she took of the fruit thereof and did
eat and gave also unto her husband with
her.
And he did eat women trouble.
What's the tree?
Well,
we talked about this a little bit
before.
So you say,
well,
if you look at the structure of
experience from this particular
perspective,
and you think about that in a vertical
planes with the layers,
one on top of another,
then you can imagine the tree as the
thing that unites these three layers.
The tree is the domain that unites chaos
and order and the individual,
the structure running up through the
middle of it.
And you see a representation of that.
Interestingly enough from norse
mythology,
this is egg sale.
The,
uh,
the,
the tree of the gods,
the tree that stands in the middle of
the norse paradise.
And one of the things that's very
interesting about this particular tree
is that if you look at its roots,
it's the roots are covered with snakes
and serpents.
Sand underneath the snakes and serpents
is water.
And so that you see that the tree it
stands at the center of the world is
rooted in chaos,
fundamentally is rooted in whatever it
is that constitutes the pre cosmogony
matrix of being.
And then the central aspects of this
domain are nicely laid out as the domain
of territoriality.
The end of the borders that the
individual understands and the habitual
territory that he inhabits,
and then the tree in the center
represents whatever it is that central
to this to our mode of being,
and so let's take a look at that in some
detail and flesh it out.
Symbolically.
We find really add is saying the tree
stands hypothetically at the center of
the world is precisely that structure
that Sharman climb when they make their
transition from the normal mode
diversely being into their transcendent
mode of being.
So Elliot,
it says,
the symbolism of the ascension into
heaven by means of a tree is clearly
illustrated by the ceremony of
initiation of a shaman.
The candidate climbs up a post in the
middle of his,
your.
His tent reaches with summit and goes
out by the small coal,
but we know that this opening made to
let out.
The smoke is likened to the whole made
by the pollstar in the vault of heaven.
So you can imagine there's a
conceptualization of the world as
centered around a particular access and
that the tent is regarded as at least
Trans Trans.
Literally as a symbolic equivalent of
that cosmological structure among other
people's,
the tent pole is called the pillar of
the sky and as compared to the pole star
around which the world rotates a,
at least from the visual perspective and
his name Dallas,
where the nail of the sky,
that's the ritual posts set up in the
middle of the court,
is an image of the cosmic tree which is
found at the center of the world with
the pole star shining directly above it.
By sending it,
the candidate enters into heaven.
That is why as soon as he comes out of
the smoke hole of the tent,
he gives a loud cry invoking the help of
the gods up there.
He finds himself in their presence.
The tree is an absolutely archaic symbol
and it seems to me most likely that it
represents the structure of the nervous
system.
I think a structure that's rooted not so
much in the spinal sensory motor
structures,
but deeply in the autonomic structure,
stretching down into the center of the
body and planting the mind firmly in its
material substrate so that the autonomic
system and its projections up into the
Amygdala and the limbic system and then
up into the cortex constitute the
interface between the spiritual domain
that our psyche and habits and the
material domain that constitutes our
body.
The tree at the center of our being.
What is it?
Tree do well,
it bears fruit well,
what sort of fruit?
Well,
there are multiple medieval
representations that are quite peculiar
showing Christ,
for example,
as the fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil,
the fruit of the tree of life,
and what does that mean?
It means that conceptualizations,
like the hero are products of whatever
it is that this tree represents.
The tree is something that produces
fruit.
Fruit is also something that can be
ingested,
and as
Eric Newman point out,
wherever liquor,
fruit,
herbs,
etc. Appear as the vehicles of life and
mortality,
including the water and bread of life.
The sAcrament of the host and every form
of food cult down to the present day.
We have an ancient moat of human
expression before us,
so imagine the idea of the piagetian
idea of assimilation and then
accommodation and then understand it's a
similar type of nutritive underlying
metaphorical nature.
The idea being that there is a tight
analogy between ingesting something
material and undergoing a transformation
of of energy attendant upon that,
right,
which is what happens when you eat and
ingesting a piece of information which
offers you a new mode of doing things so
you can say,
well,
people will trade work for information.
They will trade food for information.
There must be a kind of equivalence
between work and information and food
and information because otherwise the
trade wouldn't make sense and then you
realize that if you're informed,
you can undertake transformations of
yourself and the material world in a
much more efficient manner because
that's what being informed means and
that means that being informed,
acquiring some information and eating
something are all tied up in a complex
way into the same metaphorical
structure.
Eat something forbidden,
transform as a consequence.
Conscious realization is acted out in
the elementary scheme of nutritive that
simulation and the ritual act of
concrete eating is the first form of
assimilation known to man the
assimilation ingestion of the content.
The eaten food produces an interchange.
Transformation of the body cells through
food intake is the most elementary of
animal changes experienced by man.
How a weary enfeebled and famished man
can be turned into an alert,
strong and satisfied being or a man
perishing of thirst can be refreshed or
even transformed by an intoxicating
drink.
This is and must remain a fundamental
experience so long as man shall exist.
Eric,
new ones.
Point being that our psychological
experience of the capacity of
psychological transformation through
eating is a metaphor waiting to be
applied to the equivalent experience
that we obtained,
the equivalent excitement and sense of
transformative possibility that we
acquire as a consequence of coming
across some new and truly valuable piece
of information.
So you have any idea that the tree that
stands at the center of the world,
the individual mode of being and
something that bears fruit and the
ingestion of that fruit.
That idea say or that that piece of
information is something that can
produce a permanent transformation.